To validate our analysis,
we have multiple statistical values
that we can use to determine
the quality of our solution.
However, it's important to
view all results within
the context of our business problem.
Let's go back to our example.
We may have started trying to predict
the temperature based upon historical
temperatures alone.
And after generating a predictive model,
we discovered,
through validation,
that historical temperatures alone
are not the best predictors
of future temperatures.
Therefore we have to go back to
the analysis modeling step, and
change our model.
For example, we may try to add
an additional factor to our model,
such as the forecasted temperature, or
we may try a new approach all together.
Many times you'll go through
an iterative process
while building a predictive model
that you have confidence in.
It's imperative not to throw all of
your data at a model and hope for
a decent outcome.
The best models are those that
are created with methodical analysis.
In some cases,
you may need to start the entire problem
solving process over again and
revise some of your assumptions and
decisions based upon what you've
learned during the process.